i welcome you all
to today's webinar today we will discuss
about the upcoming three days workshop
on the introduction to computational
biology and biomedical data science
this workshop is designed for graduates
post graduates faculty and researchers
before we start with the talk i would
like to introduce us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy
we use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
mix logic research based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review
and project design
i'm honored to have been working with
the team that collectively has amazing
experiences in this area
dr alfred tober who comes from a medical
background with expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
one of these projects is the
establishment of the tuber
bioinformatics research center which has
been at the core of what we do
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
turbo bioinformatics research center and
is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right
julia panel who is an expert
bioinformatician and helped prepare many
of the materials we will use
evie tatiski who is a computer scientist
and leads the development of the t
bioinfo platform we will use
dr harpreet has an expertise in the
application of statistical machine
learning techniques on biomedical data
and the development of prediction tools
and databases
and looks after the curriculum
development
bioinformatics and data science course
development
dr mohit mazumdar who is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
over the past several years he has been
developing collaboration with
universities as a mentor and project led
for omics logic training and research
fellowship
dr raghuvendran lakshmi narayanan is an
accomplished computational biologist
with experience in large scale analysis
of multi-omics data and data science
methods in precision oncology
and protein data structural
bioinformatics
applying his proficiency in using python
r and shell scripts for bioinformatics
dr raghuvendran is interested in
translational approaches to understand
cancer biology neurological disorders
and
bioinformatics to discuss more about the
workshop
schedule and the outcome i would like to
invite one of the co-mentor and
bioinformatics specialist dr mohit
mazumdar
and hello everyone
welcome to this
session
and welcome to this webinar
so my name is mohit mazumdar and
as many of you might be joining for the
first time so i have a phd in
computational biology and i have years
of experience working on various
biological problems doing research in
bioinformatics using computational tools
so today we will start by learning why
we are doing this first and then we will
learn about the various uh things
associated with the workshop and also
the schedule and
the
experts who will be talking in this
in this
important workshop
that will be conducting from 26 december
to 20th december
so
advances in sequencing and computational
biology have uh you know drastically
increased our capacity
to explore uh biology through this vast
amount of data so our understanding of
uh the world of biology is changing due
to many breakthroughs in biotechnology
in agriculture in infectious disease
research and also in other life science
research
so that is one of the key reason that we
design this workshop for beginners and
students who are starting their journey
with their
specializations uh specialization
degrees that they are in that you are
enrolled in so students who are doing b
tech students who are doing masters
msc
mtech phd and people who are doing
research
especially
clinicians who would want to learn about
the
innovative industrial technologies
related to biological data analysis so
this program and this workshop
especially for anyone who would want to
have that who have this keen interest in
under and understanding that what is
going on so in today's world we are
learning from newspapers we are learning
from different sources about these
different breakthroughs that are
happening that that starts from the
development of vaccines to all the new
advancements that are coming for
diseases such as cancer and other
life-threatening diseases
so and people who are interested in
doing that people who have interest in
learning about that
it is quite challenging to stay up to
the speed and to learn that what is
going on and uh what are the ways we can
contribute what are the ways we can get
into it and start doing the same
so in this session uh we will learn
about topics and uh the curriculum that
will be covered in uh
that i'll be that we will be covering in
this workshop and that i will be cover
covering in this session along with the
resources that i said uh we have uh
resources that utilizes this innovative
omics logic bioinformatics training and
that will allow students to be a part of
this growing and rapidly evolving
community of researchers scientists
entrepreneurs and industry specialists
so this omixlogic short three-day
workshop registrations
will allow the participants to access
the self-learning course uh as you can
see in the screen there are uh some of
the key objectives that we have put
together so self-learning courses and
projects so these are available uh on
our propriety portal learn omis logic
and platform tbi info server so anyone
who registers will have access to all
those resources for 30 days from the day
of the registration and a training on
bio biological and biomedical data
analysis
using sequence and structural data and
then utilizing the big data
which is available on public
repositories so we will do that and over
the past few years
i would like to mention this that
our innovative technology that is being
utilized by multiple resources and
by creating pathways for students to
excel in their career has led to many
awards and recognition as you can see on
the screen
so in india
we have collaborated and piloted our
training programs with
30 universities for the last three years
testing and validating the project-based
curriculum to develop research ideas and
research projects and to support this
process
and to support this entire process from
training to be able to participate in
real and cutting-edge research
so this actually brings us to talk about
this opportunity this another
opportunity for students and faculty who
are interested in exploring the vast
multi-dimensional data and to gain skill
sets that are really
truly relevant to industry and also
academic research and that pertains to
you know deeper understanding of human
beings and all the other living beings
so the this omex logic workshop is
designed for students and researchers
who are eager to kick start their
journey to big data by understanding the
application from a biological from a
biologist prospective and solve the
challenge like an expert in
computational biology so that's what we
are going to expect from you after you
go through this training so this
especially this version of the workshop
is a special is a special opportunity
as we are glad to announce an academic
uh partnership with the premier's life
sciences
and to tell you more about this
partnership
uh that will be helpful
for all of us going through this
experience because prima's life sciences
in india is a young dynamic and a
focused organization uh introducing
these game-changing niche technologies
such as genomics
this application in cell biology
biopharma to boost innovative research
and diagnostics in india
compared to the developing countries and
during this session the students from
the experts will learn about the cutting
edge and niche life science tools for
advanced for the advancements of indian
research and clinical diagnostics so it
will be a great opportunity in that
context so in this workshop and in order
to get you all a complete understanding
of uh big data
from experts uh we designed these
workshops with prima's life sciences
that will help
address the gaps
so
that will be done via by doing a
pre-orientation workshop on 26 december
uh on ngs data generation and we will
cover next generation
machines
and some of the coolest application in
biomedical research so let's learn about
some of those topics that we'll be
covered covering
in
in this pre-orientation session so this
workshop will commence on 26 december
which is on sunday
and the first keynote session will be
about
illumina machines and data generation so
there will be a pre-orientation session
also before that for you to get started
and have all the login information and
all the access and all of that and then
we will start with the session the first
keynote session will be from 10 a.m to
11 a.m ist on 26 decem on 26 december
followed by that there will be another
session uh which will be about the
application in clinical uh in clinical
ngs and we will learn about important uh
terms and important things that are
going on in clinical engineers such as
oncology testing we will learn about
rare complex diseases we learn about
reproductive genetic diseases and
genetic health and microbial wellness
and whole genome sequencing so these are
really i mean topics that the scientists
are working on and using their the
insights from those sort of experiments
and technology is helping us to take
critical decisions uh for uh
drug development on all of that so we
will go to that one by one in this
entire workshop and really excited to
learn more and more about it and also to
tell you more and more about it so after
learning about this clinical application
we will get to learn about the advanced
technologies that are emerging to
provide even deeper understanding of
each of the cells so in this last
session of the day
dr nithya
nithyananda sharma senior product
manager singles and spatial spatial
genomics will talk about single cell
genomics and clinical paradigms so
you'll learn from data generation and
then clinical application and then you
will learn about the advanced
applications
so
followed by this uh the next part of the
workshop and the next part of the
workshop we will be learning about ngs
machines after learning about the ngs
machines and clinical application we
will be learning from the industry
experts
about the biological data analysis to
learn about big data to learn about
databases to learn about public
repositories and to learn about basics
of data science and computational
biology so these are some of the things
that will be covered in the next two
days and
we will have experts for that so for the
next two days
along with me we will have experts from
our team to take you through these
different topics that i will go through
in a while in some time but before i do
that uh let's hear from our experts who
are present
in this webinar
so
let me invite a doctor ragavendran first
who is an expert mentor and a big data
specialist so over to you dr
raghavendran for the introduction
thank you thank you very much
dr mohit let me start by sharing my
screen
okay i have to share everything so that
you can
okay i think i'm audible and my screen
is visible
yeah so i'm raghavindran i'm a resist
consultant and a mentor with pine biot
economics logic
i'm trained in bioinformatics and i hold
a phd in computational biology from max
punk institute of germany my research
interest and focus is on data science
techniques such as machine learning deep
learning and several other methods
applied to the integration of poltermix
data like
gene expression data gene mutation data
and copy number variation data etcetera
so my role in findwater includes
developing curricula and mentoring
students in the research fellowship
program so let me talk about one such
example
in which i developed machine learning
models to predict tumor responses for a
variety of treatment options employing
multi-omics integration of gene
expression data with gene mutation copy
number of radiation data so
excuse me we know that cancer is the
leading cause for diseases worldwide so
for such a dreadful disease for a long
time our systematic cancer treatments
have relied on chemotherapeutic drugs
that are generally toxic for all the
cells
and
marginally more toxic for the cancer
cells this is a problem because on an
average only 25 percentage of the cancer
patients respond positively to cancer
drugs but in comparison about 80
percentage of the patients respond to
popular painkiller drugs that are
available
so a prominent solution to such a
problem is precision oncological therapy
where the treatment strategy is designed
by targeting the molecular
characteristics of the patient's tumor
hence the treatment is personalized to
patients who are likely to respond to
specific cancer therapy there is not
sufficiently enough data from cancer
patients to molecularly characterize
tumors for different multitude of
treatment and other therapeutic options
available so hence we have to resort to
a suitable model system
in this particular data the model system
uses patient-derived xenografts and what
are patient-dealer xenographs the tumor
cells from the cancer patients are
subjected to first they are subjected to
multiple molecular profiling through
nexus
next generation sequencing techniques
and this gives information about the
gene expression data gene mutation data
and epigenetic variation data that were
extracted these data molecularly
characterizes the tumor and then these
tumor samples are then grafted into
immunosuppressed mice and
these immunosuppress mice which were
which which
hold several different cancers were
administered multiple
treatment strategies and tumor
therapeutic chemotherapeutic options and
the
tumors response to these strategy are
studied in terms of
volume size and survivability so this
data records the reaction of these
tumors to different treatments both the
molecular characterization data and the
treatment response data are available
along with the publication that was
published
in 2015. so such a wealthy of data
generally it generates lot of
interesting questions so my specific
interest was to use this multitude of
data to design and implement machine
learning models so that i can predict
tumor responses to specific different
treatments
so
most of the biomarkers data that are
obtained to date include only one ohmic
measurement either genomics or
transcriptomics or other omics data that
are available and thus they do not take
full advantage of the complexity that is
present in the system which are complex
which are captured by measuring
multi-omics data so there are several
methods
as listed here to integrate several
multiple omics data into one but
selecting the best appropriate method
and strategy that will unravel the
complementary information and integrate
this omix data into a meaningful feature
is still a very difficult challenge so
for that for this particular data i used
a very late integration of multi-omics
integration and
i also tried several other methods but
this one proved very very useful so what
happens when i do that
traditionally in treatment response
identification
research area that the prediction to any
treatment the treatment response
prediction is
is
the treatment response is predicted
using the single gene biomarker that
usually characterizes the tumor or
onset of the
oncological
condition but if this is a problem
because this
single gene marker may characterize the
onset of the tumor but it might not give
us enough information about the
prediction of the of the treatment
response so that is proved here where
the mcc coefficient which describes or
which uh which
describes the accuracy of the machine
learning model suffers really suffers to
even cross 0.5 so when i use information
from all the
all the gene genetic data then the
accuracy
increases marginally so thereby by
applying one two and even three more
omics data to the same data set my
accuracy not only increases but also the
precision also increases in terms of
accuracy
so what what could we get
usually
what could we gain from this from such a
data that
so one major uh
conclusion is multi-omics data
definitely improves the accuracy another
major conclusion is it's very difficult
to integrate several layers of
multi-omics data into very many
meaningful
data that can be leveraged so
what more could be done
such an analysis can be extended to
include patient data from tcga to just
verify whether
machine learning models that are trained
on model data most model or cell line
model data how does they perform when
they are tested on the patient data and
with this machine learning model data we
can
develop or we can generate a set of uh
interesting or important features that
will describe
a
concise list of genes or biomarkers that
can be extended to gene set enrichment
analysis kind of analysis steps to
identify uh
specific markers that can characterize
the treatment response also so
hope this was informative and inspiring
for all of you to generate interesting
research questions for publicly
available data and such methods and
and such methods and such
techniques will be briefed will be
briefed in this workshop that is aimed
at introducing several omics data and
how these omics data's independent or
integrated analysis will help you
understand relevant biological systems
we will demonstrate you using multiple
data sets that are publicly available
and are curated for demonstrating the
logic behind the complex analysis
pipelines involving machine learning or
deep learning methods in the course of
this workshop we will also showcase the
resources we designed to help students
and other users to master the necessary
data science methods at three different
level first level is at the logical
level which doesn't require the user to
be an expert at coding where you can
leverage the t bio info platforms for
your analysis by concentrating on
understanding the logic behind several
machine learning methods that are
incorporated into the big data platform
and then
analysis using r for those who are
comfortable that are coding our code
blocks and details step by step
explanation for those codes will enable
you to understand machine learning
methodology using r and then an analysis
using python for those who are
interested in python our lessons
sorry our lessons involving coding using
popular online coding resources like
google collab will enable you to
understand execute and modify our course
to fit your data of interest and will
help you master machine learning and
deep learning employing python libraries
i wish and i hope for very engaging
participation throughout the workshop
that will in improve uh employ
scientific understanding in these
different multitude of scientific
research areas i thank you all for your
attention i will be happy to
take any questions if you have any
and i hand over the podium back to dr
mohit
let me stop my share and
okay thank you
dr raghavendran now uh let me invite our
multi-omics expert dr harpreet
who has been contributing immensely to
the bioinformatics community by helping
mentoring and publishing important
resources for the researchers over to
you dr harpreet
thank you dr mohit and dr raghav
now let me share my screen first
hello everyone first let me introduce
about myself
so my name is harpreet kaur and i have a
phd in bioinformatics in my current role
i am curriculum developer and research
consultant
so here i am renting research fellows as
well as working with international
collaborators in various research
projects based on biomedical ngs data
so i would be one of the mentor in this
upcoming workshop
in the upcoming workshop you will gain
the extensive data science skills and
that can be applied on
multi-omics biomedical data
once you learn those skills
next you will you can apply all those
skills on way on your own research
projects
so how you can apply various resource
skills especially if you don't have any
previous bioinformatics research packed
on so now let me first give you the
glimpse of my research background as
well as
let me give you the glimpse of the
project that completed by a research
fellows who have no prior bioinformatics
background
so my phd was in the area of cancer
genomics where i have uh specifically in
the field of liver cancer
so i have tried to address various
concern associated with the liver cancer
using publicly available data and
implementing various
bioinformatics techniques
for example in the first project
we use last scale publicly available
transcriptomics data to identify
diagnostic biomarker panel for
hepatocellular carcinoma
so in this study we used uh 30 dataset
which containing nearly 4000 samples to
elucidate transcriptomics biomarker
panel for diagnosis and prognosis of the
liver cancer
implementing various machine learning
techniques
in the next project we
shifted to another primary liberal
pregnancy that is flangio carcinoma
which drives
carcinoma drive forms aligning the
wilder
so in this project we use publicly
available nine data set and which
containing xcc cca and the normal sample
to scrutinize cleanser
carcinoma-specific transcriptomic
signatures
implementing various data mining
techniques
like extra tree svm render forest
logistic regression
in the another project we used
multi-omics data so here not just a
transcriptomics data we also considered
epigenomics data to identify a biomarker
panel for stage classification of
hepatocellular carcinoma
in this study we taken the data from
publicly available repository which dr
raghav was talking about that is tcca
which is the cancer genome atlas
so in this study we under identified 51
signature which include 30 rna
transcripts and 21 methylation cpg site
using various biomedical data techniques
in the last project
we just not considered transcriptomics
and epigenomics layer we also consider
mi rna data so we have tried to
integrate all the three omics layers of
the
hcc basin to identify uh identify
signatures that can stratify low
reoccurrence risk group and high
reoccurrence risk group of the scc
basins
now let me give you the glimpse
if you don't have any background
uh prior background particularly in r or
python so as dr raghav
has shown you the platform that is
t-band for server and some of these uh
lessons that where we already have are
in python script so we have the research
fellows who have completed their
research process
based on publicly available data and
implementing various tools from t bind
for server itself
so we worked in various fields including
the oncology so here we have uh
undergraduate student miss
uh semedolana
uh who is from the turkey university
completed her research project entitled
long non-coding rna as therapeutic
target in chronic lymphocytic leukemia
using publicly available data
implementing various bioinformatics
tools from t bind for server
then ms usha parikh has completed her
project
on identification of the biomarker to
differentiate between neural stem cells
and glioblastomas uh stem cells
employing publicly available data
from from the glyphosate
and using various bioinformatics
techniques
then miss
ruthvaja has completed her project in
the field of neuroscience particularly
she worked on multiple sclerosis she
completed her project entitled in silico
analysis of transcriptomic profiling and
affected biological pathway in multiple
sclerosis
now let me also give you a glimpse how
data sense can be applied in the field
of infectious disease so here we have a
research follow
um that is mr supanthadi
uh he's worked in the particularly in
the field of malaria
where he has explored publicly available
transcriptomics data
for the analysis of gene expression
profile
to study malaria vaccine dose efficacy
and immune response modulation using
various bioinformatics tools that are
integrated on the t bandwidth server
so apart from transcriptomics data
so then we also worked on genomics data
so in this project we work with the uh
researchers team from naguchi memorial
institute of medical research university
of ghana
where we study the haplotype variant
analysis of plasmodium falciparum ama1
based on the genomics data
then apart from these
fields so our research fellows
after their learning they also worked in
the field of space comics
so here we have mr subrachit
uh subrachit
sorry miss uh first miss delara de kin
has completed her project using
meta genomics
where she completed her project on
radiation 3 to
human in space as an alternative
approach with probiotics using
metagenomics data and various
bioinformatics tools that are integrated
on t-band for server
then mr
subrachit has completed his project
again in the same field here he
instead of the metagenomics data he
explored the transcriptomics data
so well he has uh he worked on a project
entitled transcriptomics analysis of dna
damage response in jabra fish
embryos under the stimulative
microgravity
so then we have also worked with the
research follows from india itself
particularly amity university
so
for example we have
sharma has completed her project on
bioinformatics analysis of small cell
lung cancer patients with bone
metastatism
sorry
then is a conscious thing completed her
project on in silico analysis of ng
state of glioblastoma to understand the
impact of idh1 mutation
then mr aditya bhajpa he has completed
his project in the field of virology
where he mainly explored transcriptomics
analysis of cd4 positive t cell to
recognize gene signatures regulating hiv
infection
then ms
shruti coyle completed her project on
transcriptomic analysis for early
detection of cervical cancer
then mr riddich thakur completed his
project on the identification of
biomarker for the prostate cancer so
besides phd's uh masters as well as
undergraduate student as well as
different researchers so we have
students from high school
who able to complete their project and
able to present their project on various
conferences like miss nitra sirini
version and mr anders
has
completed their research project in the
field of neuroscience
so after we are going to lo in the
upcoming workshop so right now i'm just
giving you a glimpse how the biomedical
data and data science can be applied to
drive biological meaning so you can
implement all these skills in the uh you
are going to learn how we can actually
implement even if we don't have any
prior bioinformatics background
so my major research interest lies in
the field of cancer genomics infectious
disease neuroscience machine learning
and biomarker discovery and i'm looking
forward to see uh every one of you in
this workshop
uh if you have any question please feel
free to post your queries in the chat
box
and uh
now i would like pass this session back
to dr mohit so dr mohit over to you
thank you dr
[Music]
let me share my screen
yes and now we will learn about uh the
sessions uh how the second part of the
sessions will be day two and day three
and before that let me just quickly tell
you that what it will be about so
uh again thank you dr preet now uh let's
learn about the topic and let's learn
about what would be the pace of this so
that in this introductory workshop our
focus will be
uh to give you an in-depth overview of
important omics technologies that is
changing the way
uh
healthcare is and this entire system is
rapidly evolving so our focus will be to
making you learn about these complex
technologies uh with several different
layers so that it becomes easy for you
to learn and you have sample amount of
resources with you to take you uh which
you can take on for the next few next
one month to learn about all of this so
we will learn about obviously the next
generation sequencing technologies and
the data the different omics layer data
and then we will also learn about how
this in it all integrates into drug
discovery and how this is actually
helping in the process of drug discovery
so we will start with genomics like
giving you an overview of genomics that
genomics is an essential subfield of
bioinformatics and it's a very important
field now as a and
which is a major force in expanding our
knowledge about genetic association with
hume with diseases and other traits
so uh it's an interdisciplinary field so
in such interdisciplinary field we have
an opportunity also to learn about other
things so the other things would be to
learn about r and python how r in python
is used in genomics what are the
different way i mean technologies or
different algorithms that we use in
genomics to gain insights about
different things such as you know
multiple sequence alignment of genomes
then we are talking about you know dna
methylation factors then we are talking
about massive databases such as gene
back gene bank embl and sra that allows
us to do all of this research so this
will be focused on that and this is what
genomics is going to be all about in
this
workshop
and then
the another technology that you are
going to learn about so there are three
key technologies that we are going to
cover uh in this workshop along with
hemo information informatics is genomics
transcriptomics and metagenomics so
transcriptomics is the process by which
the information in a stand of dna is
copied into a new molecule of rna so
this transcript this transcription is
like a dynamic process right so the
transcriptome is a snapshot of genes
transcribed in a cell at a particular
point of time and this is very important
to learn that this is complete snapshot
of
the entire genes at a particular point
of time so this actually enables us to
gain a lot of information
when we compare
different
stages different
conditions so that's why we learn so
much about transcriptomics and that's
why it has been used in so much in
clinics and in research
so um the sum total
that is what the transcriptome is all
about and then we are going to learn
about uh different analytical steps so
how do you analyze once you have the
transcriptomic data it's deposited in
public repositories and you can answer
some good questions some good biological
research questions
like biomarkers and
finding critical genes that are
expressed at a certain point of time
that gives you an idea about their
function so all of that is can be done
through transcriptomics and uh what we
are going to learn is that how do you do
the processing so from a raw data so you
will learn about the raw data in on 26
december and on 27th december we will be
learning about how do you process this
raw data into something meaningful so
processing exploring and we learn about
gene and isoforms downstream analysis
statistical analysis and then
interpretation of that kind of data so
that that would be one of the key
objectives of this workshop to get you
comfortable with the visual tb info
platform to get you comfortable with the
research that can be done using such
tools and algorithms
sorry
and the next thing would be
after transcriptomics is also to learn
about metagenomics not after but we are
going to learn about these
simultaneously in a way that it all
makes sense so in metagenomics we would
be learning about microorganisms and
then
the samples that are collected from the
natural environment and we will be
learning about the community structure
because in a natural environment you'll
find all kind of species richness and
then you'll be investigating their
functional roles and how these microbial
communities are playing a key role
in human health human disease and many
sort of interactions that we are
learning from this sort of data so uh
again uh we will be going through some
of the project examples and i will take
you
in a sec in a few few more slides the
entire schedule of the program so uh
here we will be going through the gut
microbiome project we'll learn about
that we'll learn about brain access
project and then we will learn about how
this is being useful for those who do
not have any background of micro uh
metagenomic uh technology and people who
do have a background can explode more
further this like meta genomic
sequencing uh analysis you know phylosec
and all the biome
analysis that one can do with the tools
that we will be showcasing you and with
the
resources tutorials that you can take
help from to do this on your own
so uh learning about the technologies
omix technologies genetic data and now
you're looking for solution strategies
now you're looking for molecules you're
looking into structure you're into three
dimensional world
so uh from three dimension to two
dimension from two dimension that is the
sequence uh
to you know
sorry uh single dimension to
multi-dimensional data and from
multi-dimensional data we move to a
three-dimensional data and again from
three-dimensional data we will move to
again uh
matrices so again uh two dimensional
data to do data science and ai so this
is really a fascinating journey from
different type of data types that we
were going to
learn about in this
short workshop it is just to give you
that what all can be done within this
space so one of the things that is going
to be covered is uh protein folding
structure prediction because when you
think about uh you know these uh
important biological processes
you think about uh also the diseases you
think about also what is available and
what is not available for a
computational biologist and for a person
who does not uh you know have uh
all the resources to do the experiments
uh we kind of rely on predictions and we
do predictions all the time we humans do
it all the time so we also uh have built
systems to do better prediction one of
that system is google's
deep minds alpha phone so we will be
learning about how to run alpha fold and
what are the applications of alpha fold
with
different variations variants that
you're learning about how that
influences the structure and the
function
now uh
now we are back to the schedule uh for
actually the day one and day two after
the orientation session on 26th this is
27th and 28th and we have uh sessions
starting from 11 uh 10 45 a.m uh to uh 6
p.m till 6 p.m in the evening and this
all of this will be recorded and will be
shared for those who are missing out on
any of the sessions but it would be a
great experience starting from the
beginning till the end we will start
with the orientation of the program to
the program we will see if you have the
learn profiles up and you will see if
you have the
resources uh emailed to you and all of
that that you prepared for the session
to start and do some hands-on experience
and learn from the experts so we will
start from
introduction to ngs technologies
different type of technologies that i
just described to you by taking some
examples and learning some
of some of the pipelines that what we
can exp experience and what you can
extract and how do you run the pipeline
what are the different components there
so you can you're going to learn about
um genomics uh metagenomics and then
transcriptomics with example pipelines
then there's a lunch break obviously we
all get tired and after that uh we have
after the lunch break we will have the
session on how do you go next after you
run the pipeline how do you do with that
what are the different outputs what are
the different analysis method and how do
we interpret that that would be for one
hour and after that we will have uh so
these sessions will be
divided into again two sessions or once
for the first session we will be
learning about the mutation uh we will
be learning about genomic visualization
then we will be learning about the
mutation and variant analysis that you
can do with genomics so here you are
learning about genomics you're learning
about application of genomics before
that you got an overview of all the
omics technology and you would learn
about different
pipelines that you can use to analyze
such data after that
when we are done with
around 2 30 p.m so after that we start
with us specialization tracks which is
from 2 30 p.m to 3 30 p.m and this is
indian standard time so you can change
it according to your time zone
now uh we have uh in that session uh we
have application of ngs so we will be
learning about the tcga project and then
then we would be learning about uh some
of the
projects related to kovid 19 sequencing
so that is not mentioned here and we
have included that now so waste water
management so we will learn about three
case studies in brief here and then we
will actually work on those case studies
later in the last session so here you
will get an overview of what the case
studies are all about and what are we
going to do and then we will have a tea
break
so after the tea break we will start
with chemi informatics application and
case study we will go over some of the
softwares that are being used in key
informatics and give you an idea of how
and what are what are the things that
are
that you can start with using some of
the tools that are available online then
we will start with the last session
which is a breakout session where you
can choose uh that which session you
want to um you're more interested in so
is it like machine learning and drug
efficacy and or and learning about
learning our projects that are available
applying transcriptomics analysis or
genomics analysis or uh you know
structural analysis so we will have
three rooms uh any of you which you can
join and we'll be having obviously the
recording so you can uh learn about the
different sessions later as well if
you're registered participant in the
second day we will go through the
statistical analysis because all of
these technologies are producing you a
table so that table is again like a
matrix it has rows it has columns and it
is a very big table so how do you
interpret that table we will apply uh
methodologies algorithms such as uh
degs
uh some understand about the beta
diversity and you learn about from the
structural perspective as well so after
that session when we are
well versed with what all that you can
expect from this kind of data what is
the way to
learn how to extract meaningful data
because one of the challenges with big
data analysis and being a data scientist
is that you have to
analyze big data and then you have to
find you know
critical information from a huge amount
of information so that's really a
challenge because uh data annotation is
again a very trivial thing
so
we will learn about that in the next
session that how that how you can
explore unexplored data how which you
don't have any no idea about that is
unsupervised machine learning and then
supervised machine learning and we have
an expert with us on deep learning dr
agave indian as you have heard from him
so he will be taking us from that
different
different types of algorithms that are
used for such analysis and then from a
biological standpoint what all of this
analysis is making sense you need to
learn about that right you need to learn
that why we are doing this why we are
using machine learning and from what we
are getting from machine learning and
why it is helpful for biology so that is
the connection to the biology downstream
analysis pathway analysis how it is
affecting the pathways if there are
mutations how it is affecting the how it
is becoming cancerous
and how it is applicable for
meta genomics and then we have an
industrial panel discussion and we have
uh presentations and discussions where
we will be telling you about the
opportunities that are upcoming so
internship opportunities or job
opportunities or uh the things that you
need to uh be prepared for to get a job
in the industry we are we will be
hearing from some of the industry panels
coming from premier's life sciences and
pine bar tech and then we have the
certification and
um
q a and networking where you can
you know network with the
community and discuss and do all of the
interaction that can help you
maybe get different opportunities that
are there
so
that's about the workshop and that's
about the entire curriculum
about the workshop and
if you have any questions
about the curriculum and all of that i'm
happy to
answer to those questions and now uh i
will invite mr malik if she is around to
take you through the registration and
this workshop
uh registration
fees and all of that and also the
resources that you will have thank you
thank you everyone
thank you so much dr mohit for such an
elaborated uh
topic discussion
now before i proceed further and guide
you all to get the access to the uh
resources that we have on the portal
i'll just launch a poll quickly and
it would be nice if you all could answer
the poll so that we can see from which
all backgrounds do you all belong to
so my first question is uh what is your
educational background are you from a
field of bioinformatics or data science
or biochemistry or pharmacy or
microbiology or some other field
my second question is what is your level
of education
uh
are you a bachelorette have you finished
your graduation or have you completed
your master's or phd or postdoc
and my third question is what are your
research interests machine learning
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
biomedical data science epigenomics
metagenomics or computer aided drug
discovery
this poll would be on for 30 more
seconds
and thank you all for answering the
questions in the board
and those who have answered the
questions in the poll it would be nice
if you could visit the
learn.omicslogic.com portal
on your uh chrome or safari and go along
with me on creating an account on the
learn.omislogic portal and see how you
can make the most of the online
resources that are present on the portal
the poll would be on for a few more
seconds and in the meanwhile let me just
post the link of the portal in the chat
box thank you so much oh josie
those who have created their account on
the portal please let me know by uh
typing in a one or yes in the chat box
and others can just click on the link of
the portal and create an account for
yourself or sign up using your existing
google accounts
let me do that for you
if you just click on the login button
you will be redirected to a sign up page
here you can either create an account
for yourself that is just simply put in
your mail id and create a password for
yourself or use any of your google
accounts to sign up on the portal
please let me know in the chat box once
you have completed your sign up or you
if you have already uh signed up on the
portal
so minus 20 for a person with a
background of
chemistry if you are interested in
biochemistry then definitely uh it's
computer aided drug designing or drug
repurposing that you can
proceed further with and we will be
having a session on structural biology
computational biology first the
structural aspect of biology
specifically so uh there i think you
might find your research interest and
you can work on it right dr mohit
would you like to give a suggestion to
manasvini on that
okay now i would be ending the pool
thank you
everyone for answering the questions in
the poll
now if you have completed your sign up
let me just show you quickly how you can
update your profile and why is it
important to have an updated profile on
on the portal so if you click on your
mail address on the uh menu bar that you
can see on the portal on the top you
will be redirected to a profile section
it's very important that you have an
updated profile
because this is the way we get to know
about your progress we ponder your
progress at the back end and we do
feature the best profiles with the best
progress and scores on our social media
platforms and therefore it's important
to have an updated profile picture
please make sure that your name is in
title case and you have linked your
social media accounts and also add a
brief file about yourself it could be
about your educational background and
your research and trust
and also when you will be a part of the
workshop then you will get the starter
subscription active for a month where
you will get the access to all the
courses on the omixlogic portal that you
can learn from
now if i take you through the portal and
uh guide you how you can navigate
through the portal so you just need to
click on the courses uh tab on the menu
and you will be redirected to a list of
courses that you can see here on the
right side you you will see various tags
which mentions multi-omics fields and
data science
now let's see you just want to see what
our courses are present that you can
learn from so just click on course and
every course will be
displayed in the menu
and you can simply pick the course that
you would like to learn from
also if you would like to go through any
of the project examples then all you
need to do is just click on the projects
and you will get a list of example
projects where you will learn how the
methodologies and the concepts that you
will learn in the course could be
applied to answer in real life
uh i request all the participants to
please mute themselves and if you have
any question please put in the chat box
for me to answer
thank you
okay so now talking about the workshop
registration
so if you just click on the programs uh
tab on the menu on the portal you will
be redirected to list of programs here
you need to just simply type workshop
and you will be redirected to the page
of workshop on computational biology and
biomedical data science
on this program page when you scroll
down you will find uh the schedule first
of all and the schedule is listed for
the 27th and 28th of the workshop we
will be soon listing out the primals
life sciences schedule as well
on the program page you will find three
different levels that you can pick and
enroll for the workshop
the first level is the business level
that is for dollar fifteen intermediate
level is for dollar thirty and advanced
is for dollar forty five now what is the
difference between these three different
levels in the first level definitely you
will get the access to all the resources
on the loan on massage portal
in the intermediate level
you will get the access to one-on-one
mentor support that is
missing from the business level where
you will be getting the assistance only
in group meetings but in case of
intermediate you will get the one-on-one
mentor support as well and in the uh
advanced license you will get some extra
time to work on any of the projects that
you may propose uh in
during the duration of your working on
any of the courses on the portal right
so that is the difference between these
three different levels many are times
participants get confused which level
should they pick up so if you want to
work on a
short project
for
submitting in your institute as a report
or just for your experience to get some
hands-on then an advanced license will
be the best for you if you are looking
for some one-on-one mentor guidance then
intermediate level will be the best one
for you or else the beginner level is
always there that you can opt for
and once you uh pick any of these
subscription uh types you will get the
access to all the courses on the on the
logic portal just the difference would
be in the duration of the time period
that you will be getting the access to
so that was the very simple process to
get yourself registered for the workshop
i have some questions in the chat box
let me just answer
if we are in the beginner and we finish
it we can upload it yes you can
definitely
update your subscription level from
beginners to advanced
that's an option that you can pick any
time soon any
any other question
uh for heart is saying can it will be
helpful for diagnostic person
yes definitely it will be
so let's say uh now when you see a
diagnostic person are you referring to a
clinical data or like diagnosis or like
a diagnosis of a particular
tree a particular disorder or a
condition
am i right for that
molecular diagnostic right okay so i'll
uh i like dr harpley to take this
question because she will be able to
answer this question in a greater detail
dr harpreet or dr raghavanthan can you
please take this question
and tell for heart how the biomedical
data analysis actually help in molecular
diagnosis
i think yeah i think i can do that so
thank you
so for heart
i need to know uh what do you mean by
molecular diagnostics so are you uh
are you interested or are you familiar
are you
from a molecular biology background
or uh if i can see your
yeah are you working in molecular
diagnostics uh company or laboratory
kind of settings where your primary uh
job or primary uh
scientific interaction is identifying
molecular diagnostics can you please can
you please little bit more specific
so in any case i i assume that you are
going to be
familiar familiar with
molecular
biology and
okay
okay excellent in that case uh this
course will actually enlighten you on
this this this workshop will actually
enlighten you how multiple different
data that have connected uh that are
collected uh
high throughput sequencing data and omix
data are collected and how these data
are processed and how very many
meaningful biological and
diagnostic insights can be developed
from these data so you can take you can
follow the gradual steps from collecting
the data from the samples
and step by step how to convert the raw
data which is completely unstructured as
we get from many of the experimental
techniques and then convert those
unstructured data into structured data
and then how to do necessary
pre-processing and statistical methods
on those structured data to derive very
many meaningful biological insights
that's our ultimate aim to derive many
meaningful biological insights so our
question developing a biological
question is going to be based on this
how can i understand the biological
system
so in that sense
we can and
following this workshop and you can
you'll be more interested in
more interested in like something like
uh mutation analysis that dr harpreet is
going to uh
talk about in the workshop and
something like transcriptomic analysis
which can multi-omics analysis which can
be used to identify uh cancer subtypes
that will help in precision medicine you
can you are more interested in that this
directly relates to diagnostic tools
that one can relate with so
so you are also working in translational
biology so you can uh find out how
bioinformatics is going to
enable translational biology biological
insights so that is what that is what
this workshop is all about and we will
demonstrate you as i mentioned we will
demonstrate you multiple different
tutorials and
lessons and courses and programs they
are designed in such a way that
you can follow through the
lessons if you can understand the logic
so i think at this age of our scientific
career every one of us is going to be
very well versed in logic you don't have
to have a prior introduction to coding
if you have prior introduction and prior
expertise in coding then we have lessons
that cater to you too by extending our
same logical analysis to python and also
to our lessons so if you do not have
sorry
if you do not have prior experience in
coding or prior experience in
bioinformatics you are also very much
welcome to
come through the i mean to attend the
workshop and
listen to us and interact with us
the
workshop and also the programs are
designed for people who are not an
expert in bioinformatics so
uh
i think that answered your question and
also there was uh one more from paloma i
think uh
mentioned
about not knowing bioinformatics much at
all so you don't there is no such
requirement to be an expert or to be
to develop an awareness in to have had
an awareness in bioinformatics okay
yeah i hand it over back to sonalika
regarding the time
zone and other certification uh
questions that are popping up
thank you so much dr raghav
and this is uh in the isd time zone so i
think it will be best suitable for asian
countries and african countries in
australian countries
uh so uh anyone in this particular time
zone can join the workshop and others
can get the recording of the workshop so
if you are in cst time zone and uh
it's not suitable for you to be a part
of the workshop then you can definitely
go to the recording
and for the certification part this is
the certificate that you will be getting
on completion of the three days workshop
on introduction to computational buy and
biomedical data science
and any other questions
okay so i think that we are done with
today's session if you have any question
and if you face any issues while
enrolling yourself for the program plea
please feel free to mail us at marketing
and miss
miss pashthar will be there to help you
out with your enrollment
and
yes that was it for today's webinar it
was very nice to have you all for the
webinar and we are looking forward to
meet you all in the workshop and
brainstorm together thank you so much
everyone and the mentors for being a
part of the webinar
you